When I say basic emotions, I mean emotions that are shared by all humans in all
cultures, no matter where you are in the world. Then we have other emotions
that are more unique to the human condition. These are called self-conscious
emotions. Basic emotions are important for life tasks, such as protecting
ourselves from danger or achieving a goal. The basic emotions are fear,
discussed, anger, happiness, sadness, contempt, and surprised. Notice that all
of these, except happiness and arguably sometimes surprise, are negative
emotions. That is they involve unpleasant subjective feelings. There're many
distinct negative emotions. For example, anger is very different from disgust,
which is very different from fear or sadness. They all involve different
feelings and come from different things. On the other hand, happiness is
happiness and it's only just a little bit different from joy. The other set of
emotions, the self conscious emotions occur when we live up to or don't live up
to the expectations we set ourselves. The expectations of others or the rules
set by society. These emotions require us to be able to reflect on our own
behaviors. The self-conscious emotions are shame, guilt, humiliation,
embarrassment and pride.